are you are you at home right now is
that the home studio
i am at home and i'm sitting here i feel
good i just got back to l.a
yeah did you guys record uh lonely there
as well
in your in your place we de we started
it there
uh here and then uh um
justin was actually quarantined in
canada
at that time and he recorded
the song in canada how does that change
the way that you
put something together like if i mean
i'm sure because you and justin have
worked together so much that you kind of
know how
how each other works and how to vibe off
each other when you can't have that
physical proximity does that like alter
things
it's like definitely a lot of face
timing um
yeah it's hard it's definitely harder
but with a song like this is just like
so emotional and me knowing justin and
him knowing himself and
he like his trust with us it's
it made it a little bit easier but
he he's just he
honestly when we got the recording back
i was just like
holy sh like i was i was blown away
yeah the song is so like
i think it's like concise right like it
evokes the emotion
it it hits you and it doesn't overstay
its welcome
like how did you when did you know you
were satisfied with like
that piece of music you're like yeah
this is it
when we were like this story's told
the stories the story is there it's told
and and we were gonna
add we were gonna i remember we were
gonna add some more but then we were
just like
man it just feels like
you just want to get cut off like you
don't you want it you don't want that
like you don't want it again you just
want to be like i mean you do but you
want to be like
like and just like what the because it
just slaps you it just hits you so
quickly the whole song that's the effect
that i got too because i was like it
finished and i was like i'm going back
like yeah i'm doing this again like
right away
so exactly where like who came to who
with this like who was like
okay we got to make this song
so you know justin you know
i've worked with justin a lot we've had
our history
and justin's a super big fan of phineas
and vice versa and phineas is a huge fan
of mine and i'm a huge fan of his
and i remember me and phineas were just
like at the house one day
and we were uh
we were just coming up with like little
ideas which for justin and with
justin and i remember i i i hit him and
and and it's it's funny because this was
a
the song the song is is
it's it's challenging you know like
justin even like when we were about to
put out justin was like man like
i don't know like he's nervous to put it
out because you know people haven't
heard him in this
light and it's like a brand new thing
for him
and he's you know
it's a lot you know to put you know some
sometimes when
when we were like it's a lot for him to
even listen to you know
the song so it's so it was it was
definitely
it's definitely been like a like a
uphill and down and nothing because
it's it's just so emotional and so close
to his heart you know
yeah the emotion is really raw and i
think that fans
fans of his would be eager to kind of
like
to hear this side like to to get sort of
maybe confirmation about what they think
about
how he must have felt growing up and you
said it wasn't up and down to kind of
get to where
the song is or maybe even get him to to
open up about it what was it that made
him go
okay i can i can feel safe being like
honest and raw here
i think i think it was it was like
you know everyone expects justin to be
like this like oh you got
you got everything man like life's great
like and
and i think he finally came to the point
where he was like well
you know if i can expose you know even
my life you know
i this is what i told him i was like if
you can expose like
even your life like for everything you
have like you still have the same
problems as everybody else and you know
it doesn't matter
success and all that doesn't matter it's
like everybody's still you know
gets upset gets sad feels alone feels
depressed
feel you know and it's like i think
him knowing that people could hear that
and be like oh my god i'm not the only
one like
i think it was like it was so important
for him to put out because he was just
like
you know you know he's got to play
superman all the time
you know who's who's the person taking
care of him who you know and it's
so he he
i think he finally was just like just
bravery like stepped out and was like
let's
do it yeah and there's a nice a really
nice parallel in that video
with jacob tremblay playing like
essentially young just like in that very
recognizable
outfit right like that's that's like
almost like peak
that young justin right and it's funny
because you you were just saying like
well who's gonna take care of justin
and jacob has that quality of like oh my
god you want to take care of this kid
what was it like um having him step in
and did he
he must have understood like what the
emotion of this was
it was so crazy like j i remember
sitting there with justin and justin was
like
like it was almost overwhelming for him
because he was like
what like like jacob did everything he
had like the choreography he was doing
like the same
hand moments the same things that that
uh that justin does when he's getting
ready for a show
and uh justin was like
like i feel like jacob is me like and
and jacob is it's so funny because when
he
breaks out of character he's like this
little kid
like it's like he's just like a young
he's like a young like
13 year old kid that's like just stoked
talking about like video games like
running around on the floor or
joking around and then like he just
turns it on you're like
what the like this guy is like he
like jacob is i think is like
one of the next like huge huge huge
things like he's yeah he's he's so
good it's crazy like you
it's hard to even like understand that
he's that young
yeah it's it must have been wild
watching the two of them interact
definitely definitely especially him
dressed as like bieber
like it was like we're watching like
we're like i remember i was a scooter
and he was just like i feel like i'm
watching two justins
yeah you know the the whole thing about
him uh
justin growing up um lonely we see him
now
a lot in photos with haley and
for fans of his there's kind of like i
imagine there's this relief of like ah
it feels like you've found someone
that's
that understands him do you see that uh
i don't want to say like a settled sort
of thing but
that maybe that calm or the way that she
brings what like what does she bring to
his
life that you see makes him better she's
the best they're like they're they're
honestly like
they're they're perfect for each other
like like he does like i just feel like
he seems like
in such a good space and she's like
every experience i've had with her is
like
a joy and and she's like yeah she's very
she's like she's
very caring in general and and and
yeah i think they complement each other
uh it would take me forever to list like
the songs that you've had hand in that
are just like massive hits
that like my kids hum and sing like
every single day
first for a song like this was it was it
easy for you to like
find the sound did it just come out
it was we had already written another
song that day
and we were like about to be done and
like leave
and then we were like wait let's just
try one more thing and then it like
fell out it honestly it just happened so
quickly
and and and i remember um
[Music]
i remember showing my girlfriend like
right
i got into the car and like we were
driving and i was like i got this
new thing and and she was just like like
he like and then
anybody i played it for after they were
like what the
and like so instantly i knew i knew that
like it was definitely going to touch a
lot of people
because any time i played it for someone
they would like
like like they'd be like and show me
their arm with like the hairs raised and
i just like i knew it was i knew it was
going to be one of those songs
yeah you know uh justin ed sharon
halsey like all the people that you've
that you've worked with
like what's the common denominator here
like what makes these people
superstars
just to be able to
they say all the things that we're
thinking
that aren't complicated but they're like
no one said them that way before
you know so it's like you hear someone
you know you hear justin say love
yourself you know and you're like oh my
gosh i've thought these exact same
things but i've never said it in such a
honest concise like
just way that's right at the tip of your
tongue it's like all the things we're
thinking
basically these people make the
soundtracks for our lives
you know yeah and you
make the soundtracks for our lives man i
suck but ever
when you feel like that though like
honestly like when you feel like oh man
i suck like i'm in the creative
wall or whatever it is that you're
hitting up against how do you
get past it
not make music like i don't force the
music like some people like will sit
there and they'll just be like
for i'll just go like eat some food
hang out with my friends uh play games
go swimming like
i'm not gonna like i'm not gonna force
it
i'll i'll do i'd rather just tell like
far jokes to everyone until something
comes along
because some sometimes you're in the
studio and
say we're in for a few days and we make
nothing the first few days and then we
finally make something great the last
day
yeah you know you can't you can't rush
it
so who are you looking at now that
you're going like oh i got to work with
that person is this someone that you
haven't met yet or even is it just a
buddy of yours you haven't had a chance
to work with it
i just started working well i've been
working with him for a while but he's
just starting to get really big
there's a guy named the kid leroy he's
really good
um he's like a new like rapper singer
um you know for me everyone always asks
me this question
like who do you want to work with like
but
the people i want to work with they're
already so good and they already have
their own thing it's like what am i
gonna
like it's like okay yeah i want to work
with drake but like what am i even gonna
bring to the table like he already does
it he does it so well
so it's like oh i'll just let him
do his thing and and i'll just watch on
the side and be a cheerleader
you know and then a lot of my
a lot of my other favorites are dead you
know
it's i feel like i've i've been lucky
enough to really work with like all the
people i want and then when someone
comes around
i really like new artists so every time
like a new artist comes around i get
really excited you know
you